[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
today on the show is Dave asprey you
haven't heard of him well I'm shocked as
he is known as the father of biohacking
and there's so many biohacking
modalities out there now even when just
some comes to like hot and cold right uh
but he founded Bulletproof Coffee he is
for sure a best-selling author he's
working on his fifth book right now he
started upgrade labs and he has the
human upgrade podcast which I've been on
as well gosh I don't even know where to
start with this interview I came up with
a bunch of questions and I was like they
were all kind of like around the realm
of nutrition and food and I knew that
there was like somewhere else that we we
should go that wasn't places that he
normally goes in an interview and that
is exactly what happened it was like I I
just honestly think everyone should
listen to this interview everyone should
listen to this interview the information
is so like next level like this is how
to this is how to organize your life at
the next level you want to be like
upgraded you want to be superhuman
listen to this make some notes change
your life I don't even I I that's all I
can say is it has to do with how you
live your life and science around it
which is so cool because it seems to me
like we have these ideas about how
things are supposed to go and then
science kind of catches up so that's
kind of what he does he's super tapped
in spiritually so get ready like buckle
up because this is a fantastic episode
okay
thank you for listening
um please hit the Subscribe button hit
the bell for notifications and I'd love
to hear your thoughts in the comments
what is up Dave how are you yeah I'm
doing good hang on I want to first start
and uh ask about your hair what's up
with the long hairdo is there uh is
there any significance or just just want
long hair uh you know
there's a little bit of biohacker
testing going on to be honest uh but
mostly I just wanted long hair
okay well that's fine but what about the
first part you mentioned then what's
what would what would have I mean all
I've ever heard about long hair that
would be significant uh would be
something like there's like a more of a
spiritual link to longer hair like
Native Americans had long hair it's some
it's like almost like an antenna that's
like the only thing I've ever heard
about long hair
well
this actually goes back to a
conversation I had with with Rick Rubin
we were chatting about this and it was
about exactly that in in the Vietnam War
um they needed really good trackers in
the military and so they recruited uh
indigenous people from the U.S who knew
how to track and then they would get a
military haircut and they would lose
their abilities and the military was
like that doesn't make any sense and the
guys were like no seriously my hair is
part of this and of course the military
being arrogant wouldn't believe them
and finally they said okay does this
have enough times you just keep your
long hair because it lets you still do
what you do
so maybe there's something to it but
then
you're covered in little hairs too right
and we have this issue with EMF
sensitivity and we have more
electromagnetic frequencies that are not
natural in the world so who knows maybe
the right answer is that we should
actually be removing body hair uh or
maybe only having certain antenna length
hair I don't know the answer to that I
mostly just want a long hair because
well I didn't have long hair before it
just seemed like a good idea plus it's
low maintenance which I really like so
you just like pull your hair back and
then you do it and since I do it right
now I'm doing 40 Years of Zen
neurofeedback development and I'm
testing it every morning which means I'm
gluing electrodes into my hair
so and like I did an hour of meditation
Guided by our new software that that's
um about to be released and so one five
minutes after that I had a podcast so I
just went in and like watched the little
goopy electrode glue out of my hair and
like pulled my hair back I'm like I'm
good to go so why would you not have
long hair when you it's either that or a
buzz cut and that just seemed like the
wrong look for me I agree I had my hair
short for a little while and I'm growing
it out long again because I always had
like super long dark hair oh yeah and
then I had um you know
moments of short hair just to try kind
of like your long hair maybe anyway it's
so much easier when it's long it's so
much easier you actually have to do
something to it is there a spiritual
difference did you feel like more
enlightened when your hair was longer or
shorter
uh
uh I think I just feel more myself so I
don't think that it's actually spiritual
for me I feel pretty
you know I when I want to tune in I feel
like it's available
um it's not like there's always some
transcendental experience every time but
you know I feel tunable
um but I guess also yeah but also but
also my hair was never like guy length
short right so it's never like buzz cut
it was you know here at the shortest you
know like okay got it there's short but
just above the shoulders so maybe it's
different for girls because we don't
ever really most girls don't really go
super short
um but I just feel more myself and so
the more myself I feel I think is like
just better for everything right that's
a you definitely want to feel more
yourself and I know you're super
intuitive just because when we talked
last time like okay so you you pick up
stuff and there's a reason you can do
what you do so rapidly uh so you're I'm
gonna put you in the category of special
people oh
all right so you you probably would
notice it more than someone who just
never thought about it even just the
fact you'd ask the question and so then
you feel like you know you're more
yourself with long hair that's the other
thing with with hair it's so tied in
with like you see yourself in the mirror
you look totally different so what I've
done in the past like I'd like when
there was a major life change like I
don't know I'll get a different haircut
yeah right and this time like I'm just
gonna grow it out so this is taking like
a year or something I eat a lot of the
collagen that I made real popular so
um my hair grows really fast but so this
is I don't know maybe a Year's worth of
worth of growth from it being much
shorter I had the side shaved like a CEO
Hawk before this
um and so I'm like I don't know now I'm
evolving here instead of just chopping
it so maybe I'll become enlightened when
I have a ponytail down to my butt what
do you think well we'll we'll do another
show and we'll update the situation and
then all of a sudden it'll just be this
wave of long hair everywhere you know
you mentioned something that um
thinking about this myself I'm working
with um this doctor and I she was
telling me something and I and many
times along the way she's really been
very tuned in and said things that I
wouldn't think she would have said
um
already foreseeing the future in
different ways that end up being right
and I and I think that there's just
something to like
someone being able to move the needle is
someone that's intuitive actually it's
not necessarily always I don't I mean
yes intelligence is important
um uh comprehension
um being able to
create patterns and things like that
there's some some things that
intelligence is really does play a role
but I'd say Above All Else
intuition kind of Trumps Everything 100
agree with you in fact
I think one of the reasons that you do
as well as you do on the racetrack
is that you're seeing the future and
you're reacting before it happens it's
the only way you can do things at about
a sub 240 millisecond response time is
there any any possibility that's true I
do um I remember like specifically being
quite ahead of something I was at
Michigan
um which is this big two mile track
super fast we're doing like we're in
stock cars we're doing like it was a
NASCAR race we were doing maybe 220 at
least which is upper end for a stock car
and indy cars we would have been more
like 240 probably
um and I remember
restarting and thinking and really
feeling like this is gonna get crazy I
need to be ready and we CA we took the
green flag one around one and two and it
was complete chaos and like navigated my
way through it and picked up like eight
or ten spots like it was this sort of
but I was like one of those times where
I just really felt this it's gonna get
crazy right here for a second and so
that was just one example but I do
believe that I really actually believe
that even with the car I thought it's
funny you're mentioning this even with
the feeling of the car
it doesn't have to do something for me
to know it's going to so I think that
when you're an athlete or anyone working
at the higher Echelon level of
performance
I actually think that it is intuition I
I don't think it's all just talent I
think it's I think you're you're you're
a beat ahead you're you're seeing the
future like you said I I do I think
that's a really interesting point it's
how I do some of what I do too and like
you just if you're a futurist you know
the future and there's a longer term and
there's a shorter term and one of my
favorite sports is ping pong and you
watch those guys and and I play ping
pong I'm reasonably good but those
professionals they're moving so fast
there is zero possible way and I know
because of the 40 Years of Neuroscience
stuff the p300d which is the first time
your brain gets an electrical wiggle
if you're at your level of performance
it's going to be about 240 milliseconds
for normal people as they age it's about
350 milliseconds so your brain doesn't
move until like a quarter seconds but
your body can move but the body has to
make the decision so the body's really
fast and relatively dumb unless it's
trained and that's where intuition comes
from it's a body thing and then the mind
gets the signal and then thinks about it
after you already made the turn and
after the guy already returned that
incredibly spinning ball because the
amount of time for the ball to Traverse
the table is under a quarter second so
there's no way that you could think what
you were going to do with that and if
you ever play ping pong if you stop to
think what you're going to do you will
always miss the shot if you just allow
the paddle to move you'll make the shot
does that sound familiar exactly you
can't think too much no um so what are
we working with let's like this is
obvious this is a different little
little conversation but I'm fascinated
with this stuff because I'm really
fascinated with what reality is and what
we're working with and what and I think
if you if we can answer the question of
what's real what's not what is the what
are actually the um what are what are
the rules that were governed govern
under actually I think we'll know how to
live our life better so what do you
think is at play here like what do you
think is actually happening
all right this is gonna blow your mind
there's a really interesting book I mean
I've had three copies today of danger
copy and they're the dangerous kind you
can see because it's not nice so I'm I'm
vibing let's go what does your cup say
oh the best it says do stupid things
faster with more energy oh my God I love
that cup
all right
there's a book uh little known book
called the case against reality and you
should listen to it
and what it is is a guy who's either a
philosopher or a Quantum physicist and
funny enough it's hard to tell the
difference between those two in Academia
yeah and he goes through every possible
math science philosophy and moral case
you can think of
to say that there is no actual reality
that we can detect and it's provable
because of evolution
and here's why
if I offered you a life-size map of La
would you be able to use it
no
well what makes you think that what you
see and smell
is reality versus a map of reality
is this playing into the thought that we
are a simulation
no it could support that whether or not
it did it doesn't even matter the point
is that whatever we are sensing is
provably not reality there's a species
of bacteria that can detect 27 different
types of electromagnetic frequencies
that we can't
is it sensing reality or are we sensing
reality
and even better yet
you pick up your phone by the way it
says I choose Danger on my phone right
there but
you pick up your phone and you say okay
I'm going to open my email
you're not going through and going what
I'm going to do is have an electrostatic
interaction of my finger in the screen
I'm going to send some electrons through
a chip and then go through a tdma
network and all this stuff and go to a
server yeah
you just know you checked your email but
you didn't check your email it was an
interface yeah yeah to a reality that
you couldn't possibly see or create so
what the author of that book the case
against reality it says and I think he's
right based on what I see at 40 years of
Zen and a bunch of other stuff
he just says look
Evolution designs you to have a user
interface on reality that's fit for
purpose to keep the species alive
so we evolved our eyes to see the stuff
we needed to see but we don't see the
colors that bees see to identify flowers
because we didn't need it so we threw it
away even though it's reality and we
evolved a sense of smell that's good
enough to smell someone who's sexy and
smell food that's bad but we didn't need
to be as good as a dog who wanted to go
smell butts right because we didn't need
that right because we don't communicate
through scent the way dogs do so we
threw away our ability to smell because
it was a waste of electricity so our
fundamentally lazy biologically our
cells don't want to waste electricity on
things that don't help us but our whole
map of reality it's literally like apps
on your iPhone nothing we see is what it
actually is it's a representation of
what it is that allowed us to better
reproduce and survive and I think that's
right and it's amazing because what it
means is you can install new apps on
reality
so you can go to the App Store and say I
want to get a different app and then you
can do stuff and that means that when
you do neurofeedback when you do
meditation when you do breath work when
you go into the flow state that you have
to be in to Pilot a car at 240 miles an
hour and not die
you're using a different lens on reality
you opened a different app that let you
do it and what we're doing now is we're
exploring all of those possibilities to
see what humans are capable of and we're
finding holy crap they figured this out
over 5000 years ago they're called yogic
cities
s-i-d-h-i and these are mapped out
things that humans are capable of and
what I'm looking for is what is the
electromagnetic signature of that coming
off the brain because we can measure
that I've got 1500 high performance
people's brain scans they come through
and this is one of my companies come
through spend five days becoming higher
performance people and most of it is
around
throwing away useless apps and turning
off notifications because your brain is
oh I like that phone so if if you have
all these notifications popping up all
day long you can't even use your device
anymore because everyone wants to notify
you of everything so you turn all that
stuff off so you can have sanity
Meanwhile your ancient operating system
looking for lions and tigers in the
environment and looking for famines is
like eat all the pizza and run away from
anything else that you can't have sex
with like that's happening in your in
your tissues before you can think about
it provably before so what if we changed
that sensing Network so it was looking
for good stuff so it would automatically
do what we wanted and find what we
wanted because we know that what we see
isn't a full map of reality because it
can't be a life-size map it's just a
representation then we get to go where
we want to go that's what I'm working on
so what are I mean that's fascinating
yes blowing my mind and everyone else
listening I'm sure
um so what are we
that's a tough call I'm gonna I want to
hear your thoughts and I'll share mine
I'll give you a minute
um well what I'm hearing you say just
and like the first thing that comes into
mind right now is that we're electrical
beings like that's just so we're just
sort of a wiring and firing Network
um which is where water comes in as a
conductor and all these things so we're
a wiring and firing Network I think look
how you download stuff yeah I'm just
watching you do this this is cool
um so I think that we're I think we're
we're connected we're we're part of this
sort of fabric of the universe this
quantum entanglement to everything kind
of like the body is all interconnected
it might not be directly connected but
it's all connected like and we're part
of this interface Network this wiring
and firing network of the universe and
that is our Consciousness and this is
sort of an electrical
meat bag that participates in this third
dimension reality
I love it an electrical meat bag
um very elegantly put Danica yeah well
you know we got to go from quantum
entanglement to meat bag you know we got
to keep it off it's
it's I would say there's a good argument
that our our biology is a hundred
percent provably
electrical sometimes it's also Photon
based your DNA makes one Photon every 40
seconds your mitochondria actually makes
a lot of photons and your gut bacteria
makes thousands of times more than that
so there's communication with light
there's also communication with
chemicals and there's communication with
the electricity and very likely
communication with magnetic fields
particularly between the heart and the
brain and we can measure the magnetic
field coming off your heart it's tilted
eight degrees to the left and it's
shaped like a big a big Taurus advisor
in the early odds to the company that
had the first software to do that the
first device so you can actually train
yourself to have a higher power level
with your the field around your heart
which is funny because
it's also shown that when a human walks
into a stall with a horse the horse's
heartbeat patterning will shift to match
the persons and this is why Tweakers
can't ride horses if you go in there
full of anxiety the horse will Buck you
off and if you go in and you're like I
am one with the universe the horse is
like I love you and then you can hop on
my friend as a two-second intro
intermission here my friend who's very
psychic and intuitive and very
um she she said that horses live 20
seconds in the future so there you go oh
interesting I've never heard that I I
totally would believe it although that
doesn't explain why a frog will make
them buck and run away like you'd think
they'd see the Frog 20 seconds ahead of
time stupid horses
blind spots okay so the horse so the
horse you're talking about a horse well
so the the horse is reading the magnetic
field of the person before they're even
touched just in the stall humans do the
same thing so when I go and I'm on your
Tony Robbins stage in front of 15 000
people backstage before I do it am I
doing the exercises that make me have a
big ass heart field
yeah of course I am so that I can
connect better with the audience
and you said something else interesting
about intuition being a driver I just
had a guest on my show named Joy Martina
who's a intuitive and psychic and a
therapist and she said sort of intuition
is a muscle it's like you can train
intuition and if you work out your
intuition it gets faster and faster and
bigger and stronger and I think that's
true and I think that because I know
quantitatively you can train that field
around your heart and I know that when I
train my brain to go into these states
so let me turn off notification using
neurofeedback it also affects the field
around the heart so the question is
Danica where I don't know how many where
are you in the world right now
Scottsdale okay so you're in Scottsdale
I'm up in Victoria British Columbia so
we're 2 000 miles apart or something
like that
well we know that fields
continue forever they just drop off at a
cube of the distance which means they
get weaker and weaker and weaker and
then like it looks like a static but it
turns out the static is full of all
fields ever created that could get here
in time
if time's even real so it's another
great topic right in fact it probably
isn't real because we created it as part
of our user interface to reality it's
just an app we have installed
the question then is you know are we
connecting from a heart field when we're
talking right now are we connecting
because I'm seeing you over Zoom or are
we connecting in the quantum information
field
I have a question have you had
I'm sensing this like real spiritual way
with I don't know just like something's
happening something's shifted I don't
know okay
um generally speaking in a timeline I
feel like you're entering the space
really interestingly
um and I'm very interested in it so have
you had readings have you had oh dozens
of times I've had shamanic training like
okay great yeah and like 40 years of Zen
isn't as a digital mystery school like I
teach people how to do this stuff we
have psychics come in and get tuned up
kind of stuff so okay maybe I'm just
tuning in to you I'm pretty woo um I'm
also very digital and quantitative and I
like to do stuff that works and I don't
like wasting time so I reject alkaline
water outright but structured water is
the real deal so there you go yeah great
I totally want to talk about water
um so when you get these readings or
even let's say Reiki like reiki's
something that can be done at a distance
I remember that I remember a long time
ago getting a reading and I was like oh
we should do this on FaceTime so that we
can see each other and the moment that
she needed to tap in she did what I did
10 minutes ago I closed my eyes and I
tapped in I watched you do it yeah I
didn't look at you to go
um hmm so I'm not reading anything I'm
pers I'm I'm receiving I'm becoming I'm
actually becoming aware of the
information in the field as opposed to
learning it so you know what you were
doing when you close your eyes the
amplitude and location of alpha brain
waves in the brain changes dramatically
so if you want to have people talk about
Alpha Waves Alpha brain waves are very
common and very powerful and they're
nothing special unless they're organized
in a certain way but when you close your
eyes your alpha waves go up a lot and
you looked upwards so if you look up
with your eyes closed especially
focusing on your third eye if I had to
look the electrodes on your head we
would detect you going into a very
powerful Alpha state which is why when
I'm teaching people these neurofeedback
things what I'm doing is I'm putting in
dark Chambers because Darkness helps and
I'm teaching them these and then some
things you do to make it even more
powerful but what you did to tap in was
you just basically probably tripled the
power of your Alpha brain waves and if I
looked at your brain waves I would
predict we would see unusually strong
amplitude of waves I don't know how
organized they'd be and probably more
than a little bit of a lower level brain
wave that would probably be more
organized than normal and because of
what you do for a living because you're
highly intuitive and I mean I'd pick
that up the first time we talked like
you're you're paying attention to stuff
so but that's happening in order to tune
in I do the same thing I'm like you
close your eyes I don't know sometimes I
do this once I do this and you kind of
look up and then there's something you
connect to and that's why I said look at
you download yeah because so here's the
question
have you just done that since you were a
kid did you just know how to do that did
someone teach that to you because how
did you get that skill that's a great
question I mean I can remember being in
go-karting at probably I started when I
was 10 but I probably was you know 12.
when I remember maybe doing it because I
just don't remember doing it right away
but I would sit there and just visualize
perfect laughs and no one ever told me
to do that no one ever said hey sit down
and do some visualization techniques and
skills and I just decided I would
visualize the perfect lapse and I
imagined the car like it the go-kart
feeling exactly like I wanted hitting my
marks exactly correctly and so that's
kind of the first memory I have of that
but I I honestly I can't no no no I
don't really feel like I've been taught
even my
sort of spiritual awarenesses to my own
patterns of my being and why I am like I
am I mean I have therapists trust me but
it's never the breakthroughs don't
happen with them they happen on my own
they're a little spontaneous and they're
sort of like a there's a trigger
um but yeah things kind of yes things
come to me
so do you see like past lives and stuff
like that or do you have readings of
those sure I actually was in Sedona this
weekend and oh my God I'm going there
next week oh really okay very
interesting I want to know what you're
doing because I want to know if I can
come
um and I I was with this girl that I was
mentioning is very very very tapped in
and I did a past life regression but I
done I did it in a different way I've
had a couple past life I've had one
other past life regression
um and it was basically information
coming at me and she tapped into the
field and told me things and I'd ask
questions and oh that's cool I like like
akashic records reading kind of thing
pretty much that's what it felt like
more like as opposed to what I had this
weekend which was more of a past life
regression than I did so were you
experienced the life yeah where I
experienced the life I saw the life I
told the story of the life as opposed to
someone telling me a story and I was put
into like a really this is an
interesting thing I want to know it what
the science of this is because you're so
well balanced between the two so they
took me into like a deep meditation
slowing my slowing everything down and I
I left you know I I was I I was gone but
as soon as he asked the first question
I answered
and I don't remember what was being said
before that point in time it was just
sort of like a meditation to get me my
me slowed down and tapped in and
um and so I asked him when it was over
with I said did I miss a question that
you asked he's like no he said you as
soon as I asked that you answered and I
was like whoa because I was gone but I
heard the question and answered and
that's when I came to was like at the
end of his sentence and I answered the
question but I was gone before that so
where was what was happening with my
brain waves at that point in time that I
could hear him but I wasn't coherent
like I wasn't with it I wasn't present
but I was still hearing him
when you say you weren't present were
you unaware of your body
yeah I was like it was as if I felt like
I was asleep
okay you were asleep but but you you
still felt like you were in your body
you didn't like dissolve into the
universe kind of thing
no I wasn't I wasn't having sort of an
out-of-body experience that I was like
oh hang on a second let me come back
into my body to you know room you know
answer this question I just was it's
just blank there was like it was like a
blankness and then all of a sudden the
question was asked and I was like
answered the question
um okay so you were you had dropped into
um really the the subconscious state the
dreaming State and the in neuroscience
and people I'm not a neuroscientist I
just helped to develop like a
neuroscience company but my training is
not a neuroscience I'm just very
interested because I've been doing
neurofeedback on myself for 25 years
which is why I can do a lot of what I
can do so there's a state that you're in
when you're you're daydreaming and when
you're having a real dream it's even
deeper and these are different levels
and locations in the brain of what
neuroscientists will symbolize the Theta
state which is a range of things but
that's like saying oh you're listening
to music that is in the C chord like
well was it polka or it was it Metallica
because those are kind of different but
they're both can be in the C chord right
so what we don't really have good
language because it's all complex math
so what you did is you dropped into
a portion of the world of theta which is
a very big world and that's the world of
the subconscious that's where you
connect to the collective Consciousness
that's where you go to see the akashic
records and when I say to go there you
have to know how to play the right music
for lack of a better word the right
patterns within that
um so you'll see people saying well I
did some alpha or I did some Theta and
like well okay like what song did you
play I don't know well that's because
that's the hard part so you ended up
installing that app let's say or using
that app that allowed you to be at the
very upper level of theta where you're
dipping into Dreamland dissociative but
you had enough Alpha presence that you
were still able to hear and reply
um
so where are we going as humans and are
we returning or are we going somewhere
new
oh man that's a tough one
um
the most
well some of this is just opinion but
it's opinion based on you know math and
science and and also a lot of spiritual
stuff and experiential
information field Theory seems to
explain the world the most where
everything is actually a field of
information so all the stuff that we see
and sense including time including our
bodies and all that stuff is
representations of information and
there's some math that proves this and
it's the one explanation that explains a
lot of even those yogic cities we talked
about before that explains some of the
quantum effects that we know are real
and this isn't like Quantum like hey
let's do a Quantum like Quantum is
misused all over the place in marketing
if you have any Quantum prune juice
lately because I'm sure there is some
right like but in Quantum biology you
get a PhD in this it's a hard science
trying to figure out how electrons
behave in biology differently than they
do in semiconductors like it's super
technical stuff above my pay grade
um but information field Theory explains
a lot of that stuff and it says that
Consciousness itself is a field and ours
just evolved so that when our field is
in these meat suits
then
um we use the user interface that's in
these meat suits and there are some
people who are atheists who are
listening I'm gonna say well you know
that that's not true there's no such
thing as reincarnation and I only get
one one time through okay cool
um I would argue that there's emerging
evidence that that probably isn't true
but there's a very rational reason that
you should believe in past lives
why here's what it is okay and this is
why I chose as a computer science guy
who was raised as an atheist okay so I
didn't have a particular particular
spiritual bent to what I did in fact I
thought anyone who believed in anything
spiritual was an idiot until I was about
30 and just had a few wake-up calls like
oh maybe there's something to learn here
here's to being open-minded there you go
right
so
if reincarnation is real
then I don't need to be afraid of dying
because it's just starting the video
game over again it's inconvenient
okay now I can live my life without as
much fear so I can make better decisions
from a state of consciousness and
thought
now
if I'm wrong I won't know it
okay so I ran either way right so it is
probably stupid to not believe in
reincarnation just because reincarnation
as a concept creates more freedom in
your life now and if it's the only life
you have great welcome to more freedom
and if it's real then great you win you
cannot lose by choosing to believe in it
even with no evidence
so religion's a trap
I think organized religion has some
serious
um some serious limitations because what
it's doing is installing a lens on
reality that you didn't choose and this
is why most religions are like can we
have them for the first seven years of
life because after that I'm just
subconscious programming yep and then
you can undo that and that's a lot of
what I've done I spent six months plus
of my life with electrodes on my head
going in and turning off alerts that
come from organized religion that come
from society that come from pop culture
that come from bullies that come from
the best intentioned parents on the
planet still screw up all the time
because they're human right so you go
through and you turn off all that so the
goal is to be as little emotionally
reactive to negative things as possible
what I believe is that when we're in
these bodies
in fact I don't just believe this I can
prove it
um you're not the Observer of reality
right you've heard this thing the
observer effect Schrodinger's cats okay
so for for people listening
uh if you have something that might
happen when someone pays attention to it
it happens and if they don't pay
attention to it there's no Observer then
it just continues being a possibility
forever and this is provable with like
hard scientific uh radiographic paper it
it's incredibly mind-boggling so I mean
if no one if no one you know hears the
tree fall in the forest did it make a
sound kind of thing it's like Zen Cohen
land but it's real
so
if that's going on and that's a part of
our reality
remember earlier I mentioned that your
brain doesn't get a signal of reality
until at least 240 milliseconds
after something happens
um
so who's observing it
who's observing it it turns out the
front line Observer with its own
Consciousness is a subcellular component
of your cells called the mitochondria
they're not power plants in your cells
their environmental sensors in your
cells that sense the environment then
decide whether they're going to make
electricity or neurotransmitters or sex
hormones or inflammatory signaling
molecules
oh
you mean there's
billions and billions of these things
there's between 500 and 15 000
mitochondria and every one of your cells
that's not a red blood cell so your body
has way more of those than there are
cells in your body and those things were
ancient bacteria that well I would say
they moved into the cells that are us
and took over two billion years ago and
they're still driving the show because
they sense reality they decide what to
do and then we take credit for it a
quarter second later that's the seat of
intuition it's also the seed of
manifestation because they're the
environmental sensors they're the first
line observers of reality and when you
see the guys from the secret many of
whom I've gotten to know
um over the course of years and you look
at Napoleon Hill's work you look at the
way you visualize when you were 10 years
old you were manifesting the [ __ ] out of
things Danica and you were using your
mitochondria to do it you were teaching
them to program their interface to
reality to look for Success instead of
to look for failure or lack of Love or
what whatever the hell bad programming
you got somewhere so what I've had to do
probably because I had really bad
programming was go through and reprogram
all that stuff so that my mind
automatically and my body and my tissues
and my cells and my mitochondria
automatically look for the things I want
in my life I'm still working on that by
the way but we're working back here yeah
high five to the humility of it so what
are we well
you are still from the language you're
using anyway identifying with your body
you're an entirely separate
Consciousness from your body your body
has its own Consciousness that is not
you
and it does its own things without you
being able to see it it can change what
you see because it's between you and
reality it can change what you hear
and it can make you forget stuff
it can make you procrastinate and it
runs an ancient operating system that is
not you that is the platform that you
run on you are the Consciousness that
sits inside it and some of your
Consciousness is in your brain and some
of your Consciousness is non-local it's
somewhere else yeah yeah so I still
think it's fair to say what so what is
this then what is it oh that doesn't
exist your body doesn't exist
explain well at the start of this
I'm going to get to actual biological
questions and we're going to talk about
coffee but I think this all totally
plays into it keep going it totally
plays into it so at the start of this
you were finishing your danger coffee
okay while we were talking some of your
cells absorbed that danger coffee other
cells shed the danger coffee and some
cells on your arm decided that they were
done with life and they jumped off your
body and became dust
what you actually are
is you're an Eddie
like in a river a little Whirlpool
there's constantly matter coming in
you have oh about 30 pounds of air
and some amount of food every day and
you combine those to make electrons and
you get building blocks from your food
and you replace cells and you reject
other cells it's no different than water
flowing down a river
and right in front of the rock there's a
spiral of water you go look there's an
Eddy but there isn't an Eddy it's just a
pattern in reality and that's all your
meat is
yeah because there's actually not like
on a subatomic level there's not
actually matter in fact I I interviewed
a physicist yesterday and she said we
don't even know what matter is no it's
mostly empty in fact no one can explain
why your finger doesn't go right through
your desk yeah exactly I would think the
scientists that figured it out didn't
want to put his feet down next to his
bed in the morning because he thought
he'd fall through the ground through
through down to the bottom level like
that
is no
um he's uh an Indian oh called Guru
um from I don't know how many thousands
of years ago there's a famous cave to go
to he figured this out and you figure
out how to modify himself and there's
hand prints in the wall of the cave that
he did with lots of witnesses over and
over oh my God he like melted the stone
okay so without heating it up he just
was like oh this reality doesn't exist
let me just merge with it let me just do
it that's one of the yogic Cities
believe it and that's the hard part even
when we're even working with we're even
working like down the levels like to
like other things that are more simple
you actually have to believe that you
can do something you have to actually
believe that you deserve something you
actually have to believe just like that
just like he had to believe that he
could put his hands through the wall
because the wall wasn't really what he
what the wall was not solid he didn't
have to believe
oh he had to know they're different
belief implies doubt
okay I get yes I get it yes it's like
wanting and just like wanting implies
not not having exactly so believing
implies it isn't reality I believe this
to be true is different than I know this
you see how I edit my language when I'm
talking to you I always say no I don't
believe that I know that because knowing
and believing are different things
and
now even when I say no there's always a
chance that what I think I know is wrong
but that's a statement of belief in what
mil arepa was doing as far as I
understand it was he knew it in his mind
which isn't that powerful but he knew it
in his entire network of mitochondria so
they were programmed to do that because
they're the ones who had to say there is
no wall here because his brain didn't
even know there was no wall though until
a quarter second after he touched it
right because it's about programming
your network a very powerful sensors and
manifesters to do the [ __ ] you want
instead of doing the [ __ ] they want
because what they want is a simple
operating system that's at the core of
biohacking and this is like original
thinking after I wrote a book on
mitochondria all they want to do
is number one ten times focus on this is
fear run away from kill or hide from
scary things because they're dumb
bacteria individually so they just run
that all the time is that is that scary
is that scary stress stress run away
hide
or fight which is Gee do we do that a
lot in our lives yeah
and one of the things that is phenomenal
about what you've done in your career
when you're driving really fast most
people like I would so [ __ ] myself if I
was going that fast I couldn't possibly
do it and you trained your cells to not
be afraid of death and to be able to do
what they did and to handle it and when
people see it they're just awe-inspired
and that's why we like seeing
professional athletes be able to do
things that are not possible they're not
possible with your brain they're
possible by knowing in your tissues
right so that's fear the second thing
that your mitochondria are programmed to
do without your knowledge before you can
think
is to eat everything
and this is why you look down like God I
did eat the whole carton of Ben and
Jerry's what the heck who did that well
it wasn't you
it was them
and they convinced you very convincingly
that it was a good idea to take each
bite
this ancestral cellular memory it's it's
subcellular these are mitochondrons this
is what bacteria do bacteria eat
everything and they protect themselves
however they need to no matter what
right no matter what and they do it in
order protection first food second and
what would the third thing all life has
to do that's also an f word we have fear
we have food we have
it's fertility is what I was thinking
but you're you're dropping f-bombs on
your own show I'm
totally literally it actually is that f
word
um I was I always try to trick people
into saying it and it's funny but you
can say fertility you win
it's uh
and that's the third thing that you will
do and Danica everything I've done in my
life and everything everyone listening
to the show has ever done their life
that they regret comes from ancient
bacteria running that program in that
order and there's billions of them
constantly doing it millions of times a
second and that makes a distributed
intelligence that has a name it's called
your ego
the ego is the operating system that
keeps your meat alive and it is based
inside your mitochondria
and that's why we procrastinate that's
why I go on dates we never should have
gone on but they were so hot I just had
to try it and that's why I ate all the
Ben and Jerry's and all the things that
we've done and we think we're bad people
for no it's just ancient programming so
it's our job to use our mind that's very
smart and stupidly slow to reprogram our
body to do what we want to find what we
want in the world that's the seed of
manifestation is your tissues
so
are you saying it's maybe even more
important to train your bacteria than it
is your brain
yes
your body
doesn't even know you're in there
and when you show up and try and train
your body your body's like who the hell
do you think you are I'm in charge of
this meat and if I'm not in charge of
this meat a tiger is going to eat us
right now and it's an emergency so let
me distract you by the way are those
nice legs over there hey look at that
pizza hey don't do that oh are you
feeling itchy right now oh it's really
hot and it will throw every single
possible obstacle at you including
making you forget stuff
so that you won't know that it's sitting
between you and reality because that's
its job and it knows that you will die
if you're in charge of yourself that's
why overcoming your ego is so hard
because the ego can make you forget
stuff and that's why when I'm doing
those 40 Years of Zen type programs
when clients come in it's five days ten
hours a day electrodes on your head and
as soon as you come out of it we
interview them right away and they're
writing stuff down and there's a couple
other people in the room that are
witnesses because once you tell someone
your dream you can't forget it but if
you wake up and you have that dream an
hour later is gone who do you think
erased that dream your ego's like hey I
was doing maintenance work you're not
supposed to see that like let me just
let me just remove the evidence
Isn't that cool yeah that makes sense
because you're totally right you wake up
and you're like oh wow and you've got
like a decent clear view of it and then
you get up and you're like I've even
thought to myself oh there's no way I'm
gonna forget this
and then I absolutely forget it but if
you set tell the story or if you write
it down
you remember it
that's why journaling is so important
that's our writing goals is so important
and one of the things
um that I teach when I'm doing that side
of teaching versus like nutritional
stuff or whatever
when I'm doing the 40 Years of Zen thing
is that
that forgetfulness is so powerful that
well if something can make you forget it
how would you know it was ever there so
if anyone listening to this right now if
you have a sheet of paper in front of
you and you have a pencil and you say
I'm going to carry this piece of paper
around with me all day and every time
anything good happens to me I'm gonna
write it down even like oh look that
flower smelled pretty I'm gonna write
down the flower okay at the end of the
day you could have 20 30 40 things on
your piece of paper
okay
if you the next day don't have a piece
of paper and you wait till the end of
the day
you're going to maybe have three things
you're grateful for and this is how
powerful the system is okay I mean
you've you've written a a big book and
I've written now I'm I'm about in in
March I'm publishing my my fifth book
that will be a New York Times bestseller
and
well on my third book
I got the call from my publisher that
every author wants to get
and the publisher says Dave
congratulations they just released the
list your book is on the list I'm like
this is amazing you told a couple of
friends people in the company
Night comes around I'm like oh I'm gonna
like name three things I'm grateful for
guess what I forgot
I got the book I forgot that I hit the
New York Times list
and how could you possibly forget that
it's not because I'm a bad person it's
not because I'm stupid it's because I
have the same operating system of
everyone on the planet that makes you
forget good things and focus on bad
things because you have to know about
the first f word fear because something
might eat you right now
so if you have a forgetfulness system
then you need to make a remembering
system and part of that is training your
brain so you spend less time and fear so
you can spend more time in Consciousness
and then Journal it write it down put it
in your phone and having a gratitude
practice that's not just end of the day
like I do with my kids but it's
something that you do throughout the day
and one that is written down at the end
of the day like damn today was a good
day and if you don't do that at the end
of the day someone cut me off in traffic
and you know I ate two Donuts instead of
one and I'm a bad person whatever weird
internal notification based childhood
programming dialogue you have it's all
[ __ ]
so the cells forget where we came from
because it makes us scared well they
want you to maintain an alert State
because from this perspective of a
little bacteria driving a cell that's
part of this big thing all they know is
that there's some other bacteria around
and they talk to each other via
something called mitochondrial Quorum
sensing and they know that they have a
petri dish which is you and that they
can control it you're a remote control
vehicle for them
and they know that if something eats
their petri dish
it's probably the end of all life on
Earth because they do not understand
context they don't know there's billions
of people they don't know there's
abundant food they don't know anything
other than what a bacteria knows because
they're not they don't have enough
computing power they don't have enough
brains they don't have enough sensors
but when you put quadrillions of these
things together they can form a picture
of reality but it's one that only
includes what they think they need to
know to survive so the flaw in humans is
that we're way more fearful than we need
to be and that's why we do all the bad
stuff to each other and that's why you
know we have government shutdowns in
global Wars and you know narcissism and
sociopathy and all that a lot of that
comes from just Ancient Ancient cellular
programming and we can reprogram that
and I know that because I've done it to
myself and I've done it to 1500 other
people now and what you see is massive
shifts in where the brain allocates
electricity so you come through and the
fundamental technology Danica that
allows programming turn off
notifications it's a really amazing
technology and since I'm on F words it's
also one
it's called forgiveness
so
something bad happened once and your
meat operating systems like it might
happen again and if you can be like that
Grudge is just it's dysfunctional it's
not helping me anymore it's not keeping
me safe maybe I'll just turn that Grudge
off
well it's not like there haven't been
religious sages teaching forgiveness
forever and that almost every religion
and spiritual practice out there has
that as a part of what they do because
it allows you to spend less time in fear
and more time in the fourth f word I
haven't mentioned so in order
fear is most powerful than food then
fertility and friend and friend is the
first really good one
so yeah fear food [ __ ] friend there I
said it but wait I thought forgiveness
was forgiveness one of them uh it just
happened to match his Netflix is a
technology that allows you to spend more
time in this because all cells
all bacteria all zebras all trees they
all run the final thing which is be
friends with what's around you support
others of your species and support other
species this is why bacteria make yogurt
this is why kombucha has that weird
floaty thing in it the scoby and this is
why
animals will make a herd or humans will
make a tribe this is why without
thinking you will step in front of a car
to save a child that's not your own you
don't have to think because your
mitochondria know that's what you do to
keep the species alive
and then we call it Courage but what it
was was just stepping out of fear and
letting your body do what it's wired to
do so we're wired to be kind to each
other we're wired to support our society
to support each other to take care of
our elders but we will not do the fourth
f word if we're stuck in fear in hunger
or lack of love so you go through those
because you get those you're like well
what do you know now I can actually
serve others in a really meaningful way
thank you that was I loved hearing that
and it made me think of something that I
experienced in this sort of Auto Body
out of body experience and that's that
um
love is all there it's like the whole
overwhelming feeling of love and that
ultimately to cut to the chase is that
no matter where I'm at and what I'm
doing or how far I Stray From anything
like it's always okay and that there's
no need for forgiveness
because there wasn't even a judgment in
the first place and so
I don't know if that resonates and I
wonder if forgiveness
and retraining your brain
gets you on the path to then not being
triggered there's no more ego alerting
you to danger and then when something
happens it just happens there's no
judgment there's no need to forgive
there's no need to forgive them or
yourself and that things just become
thing it's just things happening
wow I I love where you're going with it
we would have to Define forgiveness
so most people when they hear
forgiveness
they imagine going up to someone who
wronged them and saying I forgive you
right isn't that like what you would
think it would be yeah it's not
so
forgiveness is simply the
energetic and cognitive Act of letting
go
it's setting down a grudge that's
harming you and not harming the other
person
you can tell someone you forgive them
and also like I've had people come
through the program who've been terribly
abused in all sorts of ways we're not
going to talk about on the show but the
worst ways you can abuse people
they're not going to go and say hey
everything's good buddy no they're just
like I have let go of all Trauma from
this I have forgiven the person
internally and the person's a bad person
and they're not a part of my life
anymore because I'm smart right that's
okay good job it's not them it's not
telling someone I forgive you there's
not that's not releasing the tension you
do it yourself for yourself yes and it's
not condoning whatever someone did
because people do bad stuff because out
of that first f word fear usually so
okay that person did something really
bad but I'm done with that and I I
remember the first time I saw an example
of this was before I had had built this
into the practice at 40 years of Zen
with the computers helping you reach
those States
um I was just flying
um to somewhere in Washington DC and I
was sitting in first class and there was
this old guy sitting next to me probably
at the time he must have been like 30
years older than me and I was like oh
what do you do you're bored on an
airplane this is before we all had your
your buds in he was oh I worked for the
CIA
I'm like really tell me about it like
that's amazing and he's he's like oh
yeah and he tells us he tells me stories
he says oh yeah I was tortured actually
three different times but it stuck with
me because of the way he said it it
wasn't like oh yeah I was I was tortured
and and so many bad things happened and
I I'm brave I'm gonna talk about it I
heard someone call it victim porn where
like people sort of will repeatedly
re-traumatize themselves by telling
their story with tears in their eyes
and it can be really addictive to watch
that but it isn't good for the person
telling it or the person hearing it
necessarily unless it's to connect with
empathy but when this guy told me it was
just so matter of fact and curious and
completely
non-traumatized yeah unattached
unattached so what you'll find is if you
want to really truly forgive something
or someone because sometimes you know
your tissues are stupid they can be mad
if someone beat you with a belt they can
be mad at the belt and seriously doing
what we call the reset process
um and the reset process is something
I'm going to teach at my biohacking
conference in September in La by the way
you should come and so the reset process
is uh it's a forgiveness thing you can
do and you can forgive an object that
your body feels wronged you and it's so
weird some people okay like if someone
spanked you with a belt who shouldn't
have when you were little every time you
see a belt if you're paying attention
you'll feel your heart clinch a little
bit sure you'll feel that the hair is on
the back your neck and you'll just like
a little bit and if we were measuring
you digitally the conductance of your
skin the electrical flow would change
and your body would get ready to fight
yeah or to flee or to freeze even just
like I mean I have a CGM on and like you
know you can get mad and all of a sudden
your whole body is informed quantumly
that there's stress in and your whole
body now now all of a sudden this little
drop of blood goes oh um your blood
sugar goes up like the whole body
becomes informed it's fascinating it's
super fascinating right so you want to
run the reset process so the next time
someone you know puts a belt on in front
of you that you don't have a subtle
stress response now you can do this most
of my clients are like successful
entrepreneurs
um you know celebrity types who are
looking for the next level performance
but they all have stuff like this
because it's just part of being human or
of just a subtle fear of heights you're
like I know that I'm safe so every time
I'm near an edge I just man up and I
just do it but it costs you energy to
just man up wouldn't it be better if
there was just nothing triggering you in
the first place yeah yeah so the reset
process
uh we do it with electrodes on your head
which act almost like a lie detector and
they guide you into this very very
specific State and what you do is you
take the person or the thing who wronged
you and you sit them across from you and
you close your eyes and you know you're
doing this it's better to do it in the
dark but at least with your eyes closed
um and
you put the person sitting in a chair
across from you and
you look at them and you say you don't
say it out loud but you say all right
here's what you did
okay and it has to be a specific thing
and it can't be like you were a monster
it has to be you you and the person as a
practitioner and a patient or is this
you can do it by yourself because it's
an imaginary person sitting across from
you it's imaginary so literally like
let's say that you know you're you know
your your dad didn't give you dinner
when you were seven and you're still
pissed about it honestly this this kind
of stuff happens all the time because it
doesn't have to be big it just has to be
movable in fact everyone has work to do
on their parents even if you had great
parents because like something something
always happens that made you mad as a
kid that your parents didn't even know
made you mad right because kids are all
emotion and not a lot of thinking in
there because their brains aren't formed
so you just you remember this it always
stuck with you right so it just where it
just popped in your head so I'm just
choosing an easy one and then you say
okay so you mentioned well what'd your
dad kind of look like so you close your
eyes you're here and your dad's there
dad you know you denied me food uh when
I was little so first is what did they
do and the second is how did it make you
feel
right and then you say it made me feel
okay and then when when people are in
the Chambers doing this or have these
specially designed Chambers to create
more calmness then you actually got a
new feel as much of the anger and pissed
offness as you can channel from that
time kind of like you did in the
regression you did like both house lives
you actually you feel it it's all
feelings it's not thoughts right and
then visceral too I mean you should feel
it super visceral if you're in your skin
you're crying you can start sweating you
have to start racing it once it's
visceral then you know yes and with
electrodes on your head we can tell with
your brain waves whether you're faking
or not because your ego may tell you
that you're doing it when you're not and
we're like ah
you got to change your brain waves too
and they're all right fine so then you
go and you actually really feel and
that's the hard part feeling it and then
there's another state that happens and
that's where forgiveness start and in
the reset process
the important thing is gratitude
so you cannot forgive a thing or an
event or a person or even forgive
yourself
until you find gratitude for the bad
thing
and this is the thing that's missing
from a lot of forgiveness literature and
this is provable that this is like core
40 years as in 101. that resonates super
deep yeah right so like okay let's say
and I'm going to make it a little bit
personal
um so let's say that you know you might
have been in a fender bender on a track
sometime that maybe was a little bit
tough on you sure maybe happened right
yeah exactly okay so let's say
um something like that
um you know left a mark like okay I'm
going to give forgive myself or the car
or the track or you know whoever didn't
change your tire right whatever the heck
you know internal dialogue you have
going on whatever feels like you should
do and maybe all the above right and you
do that and then what's one good thing
that came out of that fender bender
yeah you know you learned something you
learned what you have to do you learned
who not to trust and it doesn't have to
be something big it can be like the
simplest dumbest thing like literally
could be well you know I've had people
say it's the worst day of my life and
I'm like do you saw both your legs and
like yeah I'm like it wasn't the worst
day of your life so be thankful you have
both your legs after this like just move
on find a good thing because in your in
your automated like operating system
your
your ability to hold a grudge and be
grateful you cannot do it so that tiny
spark of gratitude is the thing that
starts the fire of forgiveness and then
forgiveness is something you do and it's
a feeling in your heart and it's a
specific brain wave and I'm using the
tech to guide you into the right State
and it's similar to a thing you can do
with a therapist called EMDR where
they'll also love embr okay me too MDR
is powerful not anyone listening if you
have a trauma that you know about you
can go to EMDR and it'll be better in
like one or two sessions yeah
you know it it's not the same as as the
reset process but the similarity with
the MDR is you go into the state of like
ah like that was icky but there's
another state that's the opposite of
that and when the body says wait I
cannot possibly have been as much of a
threat as I thought I was because I just
experienced this exalted spiritual state
of heart openness and beauty and and I
just experienced gratitude so then it
realizes
my programming was wrong I had the wrong
threat detection system let me just
erase that and when it's erased it's
actually gone yeah I look at it almost
like time travel it's like it is time
travel back to the time and you
reprogram the event
and this does a ton of personal
development work Danica you're
interesting like it is that but most
people don't say it's time travel
um but yeah you you go back and your
body doesn't really know about time
because it's a bunch of dumb bacteria in
there anyway so they don't know and
here's the weird thing when someone does
those five days of if it's like just
deep it's meant to replace Decades of
meditation in five days which is why I
keep using it as an example because it's
and I can see the numbers
um
when they're done they're like oh my God
I am so different this is amazing but
then six weeks later it's like yeah it
wasn't it was awesome it it made it made
a difference you know I still remember
it was really good but I feel like I'm
myself again and then you ask their
spouse or their friends like are you
kidding me like you're a completely
different person
but already what's going on is it it was
just you but more you and your memory of
every event once you do a forgiveness
process your memory is no longer
emotionally charged so that's why that
CIA guy could look at me and go yeah I
was tortured because he done his
forgiveness work yeah but when Joe
dispenza need to like because you guys
are both so spiritual but yet so
intimate I love Joe's work he's he's
been on my show I'm gonna go do one of
his events coming up here I just had
dinner with him and some of his his
inner circle supporters
um like last month in San Diego oh okay
um I love Joe
he loves his wine oh he's sure does
that's in fact that's the only time in
the past
honestly I think the past 10 years I've
had four glasses of wine because it was
yeah did you make you chug one
part not that kind of wine man that was
like I forget it was wine that was uh
probably older than I was it was really
good yeah he loves his wine he's I just
you guys are just striking sort of like
um approaches and states of being where
you are all into the analytics putting
the skull caps on reading brain waves
but yet still so tapped in and so much
awareness for the spirit realm and also
it just kind of the spiritual or the
more metaphysical realm where
how we go about our lives in the best
way possible to create the most amount
of joy and happiness and
um I just think that you guys I I love
like it's almost like when it feels like
when the two people get together that
are in sync it's like a spiral in fact
this is actually how I see like future
relationships is that two like really
Sovereign people and like really in in
there in in their Flow State all the
time come together and it creates like
vortexes almost of like energy and that
sort of that's like next level human
beings in my opinion but we we can all
get there uh I would argue that some
people maybe have been around a few
times more than others would say being
around is in that reincarnation
conversation we had earlier there are
some people who are born when they're 10
years old they just naturally know to
visualize success even though no one
told them to gee I wonder where that
came from I totally thought the same
things I'm like how do you explain old
souls I just how do you explain old
souls how do people just know how or
what to do something or like a prodigy
that knows just how to play the piano or
how to write music or how to do art like
or any of those kinds of things it's
like how do they know
you know when you reach these Advanced
States and I'm not saying I've reached
all of them by a long shot but I've seen
enough and experienced enough there are
people out there who can say oh yeah in
that life
I had this skill
therefore in this life I do and as soon
as they have an awareness of a past life
like all of a sudden they can
do stuff they couldn't do before they're
tapping into stuff
and it's it it's it's just a more
complex world than we think and the
danger right now Danica is that there
are a a group of people who truly
believe that we are meat robots
and that everything that we are is is in
our in our skull and I don't think that
matches reality yeah aren't they well I
I don't know that that's one lens on
reality
um but you know maybe maybe we just call
them reptilians and they're you know AI
you know constructs from The Fifth
Dimension who the hell knows right I
don't have to label them and maybe
they're just misguided people right I I
don't know like it could be any of these
things and and we all see different
things in different ways but
um there are people who are out there
saying you know we're meat robots and
you know a calorie is a calorie it
doesn't matter where it comes from it's
okay to destroy our soil and our planet
and it's okay to lie to people and tell
them to eat fake vegan food and convince
them it's healthy just because we'll
make more money it's okay to buy all the
farmland and then to stop using it to
make food right in the middle of a food
shortage and they do that because they
don't value the human spirit
or the human soul and they don't even
believe it exists because they think
we're meat robots and that when you die
you have to you know freeze your body
because this is your only time around
they may be right but honestly guys
could you just hear the thing I said
about reincarnation just decide it's
real
and then you can just stop all that [ __ ]
thank you for connecting that loop back
around again because like just it's
almost like when people have it's like
trying to it's like a it helps you live
your life better it's like anxiety
people that are worried about something
that might happen it's like you can
learn worry about it now and then when
it happens or you can maybe never worry
about it or just once but for sure
you're doing it one extra time for
nothing
you know there's two things that really
are just irritating and one of them is
worrying right like I'm gonna play this
potential story of the future over and
over and the thing about worrying is
it's coming from those ancient
mitochondria program to look for that
threat but the more they look for it the
more they find it so worrying is
provably bad for your outcomes it it's
manifesting in a negative way so you got
to learn how to shut down the voice in
your head and I had all the critical
voices and worrying voices and all that
I did enough you know shamanic training
and meditating in the Andes and
Himalayas and you know Ayahuasca and
Peru in the 90s when you know they
actually told me that yeah that's ahead
of the curve well they actually I was
asking around and they're like you're
white yeah I know but that's only for
local people I said look no I've done my
research I really have come here and I
I'm choosing to do this and they found a
shaman for me and all
um but yeah that was before it was a
tourism thing and I actually think it's
it's a little bit dangerous to do it
without the right supervision oh it's
always dangerous to do yeah
um they're safer medicines out there
um like anyway not to get diverged there
like safer medicines alike
um oh like almost any of the other
psychedelics
um so do you want okay do you want to
know like the order of options for
Altered States work for trauma healing I
would love it okay
um I gave this as a talk I was with a
group of really highly successful people
looking at
um extreme longevity which has been an
area of focus for me for for a long time
and one of the guys I got up and said
you know I have done 50 plant Journeys
this year
and it's been life-changing and you
should all do this too I'm like there's
two billionaires in the audience here
right these are people who control
masses of jobs and and to a large extent
they control some of the future because
if you're a billionaire and you're like
I'm gonna put 500 million dollars into
destruction of soil or saving of soil it
actually matters a lot more than my
32-acre regenerative farm right like
like they're moving the needle
um so I said I Gotta Give a talk after
this I said guys I have tried these
things I've done the trauma healing work
so here's what you do
okay
step one
do some breath work
just maybe we're gonna say breath work
and meditation and if you're not getting
there fast enough okay step two
uh maybe you should try EMDR which we
talked about just a minute ago because
it's really fast right and if that
doesn't work then let's go lightweight
try some MDA which is different than
MDMA it's without the meth part of MDMA
so MDA is more heart opening and less
stimulating than MDMA and if that
doesn't work do MDMA
and if that doesn't work do ketamine
which is very safe and I'm saying do
this with a therapist I did one of my
podcast episodes I went I got injected
with ketamine at a uh at a psychiatrist
Clinic just to you know talk about what
it does and to experience it
and if you're still not getting there
Academy is very powerful for forgiveness
I would call it the Forgiveness Mall
because really good for forgiveness so
you you and then okay like still out
there with ketamine all right well then
maybe you could try
LSD
and if it's not there okay mushrooms
problem with mushrooms is you don't know
what you're going to get there's you
know 100 different kinds of mushrooms
picked from different sources and they
um
outwards some you know some are really
strong some aren't as much I agree I
love mushrooms depending on which ones I
get and so I just don't like the
variants there
um and when it comes to plant molecules
like that
um there's also like energetics like was
it picked under a full moon was it
picked by like a very angry person I
think it matters and so do the shamans
who have taught me these things so
um I just I don't like the variance
there but LSD is relatively stable if
it's actually LSD then it does what it
does because it's a synthetic molecule
yeah and then after mushrooms
and then you would look at doing DMT
then 5meo DMT oh yeah I've heard about
that I don't know much about the five
Meo one and they're relatively similar
um but the Mia is a little bit stronger
and if you still haven't got there then
you hop on an airplane
you fly to Peru
or maybe Ecuador or somewhere where
there's someone who has taken
Ayahuasca on a daily basis
for decades
any sits you down
I like that you're drinking out of a
vial that's excellent or like a Beaker
Beaker I'm kind of a nerd that way
but you do that
and then they put you in a ring of
stones and do a bunch of incantations
and have you eat a special diet for a
little while and then they do the real
deal because I remember when I did
Ayahuasca the one time I did I've been
called to do it since then
um I I went down there I said okay look
I'm fine and the person I was doing it
with also it was throwing up and
everything and he'd given me a triple
dose but I just I process I didn't throw
up I said I'm gonna go for a walk like
I'm and he goes no you can't and I'm
like look yeah I can touch my nose I am
not high it wasn't hitting you right no
it did hit me I I had my experience but
I was just done with my experience and
so this is after it I definitely had
gone and visited stuff
um
and I said I am totally okay I just want
to like walk and he said do you see the
Ring of stones and I said yeah he said
those stones are there to keep things
out
because you are still open and if you go
outside that ring of stones I will have
to remove all the things that are going
to stick to you and that's a lot of work
and I don't want to do that that's a
real Shaman the job of a shaman in a
plant medicine ceremony with that
substance is to keep all the bad malware
out of your system that can enter which
is why I recommend more caution with
Ayahuasca than I would with any of the
other things and that order of
operations oh I forgot the one after
breathwork meditation MDR
tantric sex you should do that before
you start going oh that one I had to
cross that one off the list there you go
about 20 of people it will report in
surveys of like having profound
religious experiences during orgasm and
their partner just sees them twitching
and having a good time but they're me
and God so yeah yeah I agree I mean
that's a what a cool like hierarchy list
and you're totally right like Ayahuasca
has become so much more mainstream and
dark people targeting famous and Rich
and powerful people with Ayahuasca and I
don't think that that's always clean
sometimes it is but there's there's some
stuff I don't I don't always like there
but there's also some good stuff
happening yeah yeah well
all I can think of is literally coming
home like in the middle of a ceremony
two nights second night midnight wake up
we gotta pack our bags and leave because
the borders shutting down in the morning
oh wow that was how session that was how
night two ended that's a big wake up
yeah I don't yeah that was a I don't
know there's still I don't know I don't
know what the repercussions of all that
was but all of this makes me wonder
about like replenishing about the food
part right and the hunger and so I had
like all kinds of questions I totally
didn't ask you about but we got to talk
about I want to talk about the coffee
but I want to talk about the What is the
we're just we're not even matter and
we're just energy like where does food
play its part
well
it's the second f word is food so fear
and then food
and my most recent book is called fast
this way and it's about when I fasted
for four days in a cave outside Sedona
actually
um and I was dropped off by a shaman and
I needed to be alone
um because I knew that I would be hangry
and hypoglybitchy and if I was somewhere
I'd probably eat something so I'm like
there's no food no people I'm just gonna
have to face this and this was around
2008 and I
I did that and I couldn't believe how
much energy and how much power had it
I'm like oh my God I thought I would be
close to death after four days but the
reality was that I was energized and I
could walk 10 miles in the desert in the
heat with a backpack and not even care I
was like so powerful and I used that
metaphor throughout the book to teach
people about intermittent fasting which
is gaining control over fear of being
hungry because the thing about food is
that if you don't have enough minerals
in yourselves if you have the wrong fats
if you're protein deficient
if you have blood sugar regulation
issues it will trigger more Cravings but
it will also put you into fear of
starvation mode yeah so if you want to
be a more conscious person you need to
learn how to not be afraid of hunger so
fear of starvation actually would spiked
cortisol then because of the fear of
starvation it's part of it so some
people don't have a fear of starvation
and just fasting for a long period of
time is a physical stressor so that will
raise cortisol if you just don't have
enough food and you're exercising for a
long time that's normal and healthy and
the reason for that is cortisol breaks
down muscle to give you sugar there you
go add some blood sugar everyone's happy
right so there's another thing though
where a lot of people like oh my God if
I don't eat and I feel hunger
I know that my body is going to go into
starvation mode because I heard about
that in the 80s from you know a
nutrition magazine or something so I'm
gonna starve so fear of being hungry can
raise cortisol and it's a major issue
and when people do their first 24-hour
fast it's like they walked on coals at
Tony Robbins or something like oh my God
I can't believe I did it and the whole
point is that you can do a 24-hour fast
and you can even have a few things that
make fasting not even painful at all and
all of a sudden hunger goes from being
an emergency
to being you know I guess I should eat
but if I don't eat for another day or
two I'll be fine hunger's a gentle thing
and that's where I am as a guy who used
to weigh 300 pounds right I used to eat
six or seven times a day and constantly
snack and now it's like I don't want a
snack I wouldn't want to do that but one
of the underlying things that creates
hunger is a lack of minerals and right
now
our soil has been depleted by over
farming oh look at that you have some
days with minerals well it's empty
because I put it in my machine is that
why there's biomass and vulvic biomass
yeah
so it it turns out that your food is
stealing minerals from your cells if
you're eating grains or even if you're
paleo and you're eating nuts and you you
believe that stuff about beans and seeds
and legumes making you live longer even
though it doesn't appear to be real what
one of the many things they do that you
don't want is they are sucking minerals
out of your cells which means the cells
can't do their job and we just talk
about how the seed of Consciousness at
least of the ego and of intuition is
yourselves if your cells don't have
enough of a trace mineral they cannot do
their job and then they panic and they
go into hunger mode and they give you
anxiety so much of our anxiety is
because our cells didn't have what they
needed our cells were hungry and since
all this manufactured processed
plant-based food is sucking minerals out
of our bodies via oxalic acid via phytic
acid
we need to do something about it and the
answer is not to eat more vegetables
because the vegetables are grown in soil
that doesn't have minerals anymore the
only thing you can do is add minerals so
now when you drink your coffee danger
coffee has ionic minerals in it
that can open your cell membranes get
into your cells they can bind to toxins
and the coffee is of course mold free
because I'm the guy who like hey mold is
a thing because when you get mold wait
doesn't mold make antibiotics which kill
bacteria yeah are your cells powered by
bacteria yeah so when you get these mold
toxins that are very common in coffee
and then you drink the coffee in an hour
later you're like I Jitter anxiety and I
need some sugar
that's not caffeine that's mold in your
coffee and you drink coffee without mold
and you're like oh my God I feel good I
am afraid of normal coffee that's why
this is my second mold-free coffee I've
launched in my life and the guy who
created Bulletproof Coffee and this is
real dangerously good
for everyone I tell everyone if you want
if you the most important thing actually
friend who asked like okay where do I
spend my money should I do this should I
do peptides I'm like no no like no it's
not really no I don't think so she's
like what about and she's like coffee
I'm like 100 I'm like absolutely and
she's like oh really I'm like you drink
it every day literally every day this
isn't something that you do for just a
little bit or every now and again every
day so yes something that you consume
every day should be the highest quality
possible and so I was like the simplest
thing is go get Bulletproof Coffee
because you know it's clean it's readily
available so thank you for making it
readily available I mean shoot I took a
boat trip for my birthday for my 40th
birthday and I put on the request list I
was like Bulletproof Coffee because I
knew that it would be clean coffee the
whole time I was there for a week nice
now this was before danger coffee came
out or yeah well this I mean I keep
looking in the aisles for danger coffee
right next to the Bulletproof Coffee
it's not it's not in stores yet why but
takes a lot of time to get grocery
distribution and this is this is a
really clean coffee the the price to get
this grade of just flavor of coffee yeah
is almost as much as the retail price of
most coffee at the store so like this is
okay yours is what 15 bucks a bag for
the for bulletproof and like how much I
don't know what the bulletproof is I'm
not involved with bulletproof anymore
um but I just don't track it but I know
like an average bag of coffee even if it
doesn't say mold tested anymore on it
at the store just from any kind of brand
would be somewhere between ten dollars
and maybe sixteen dollars Seventeen
dollars and we pay more than ten dollars
for what's in the bag yeah and so if you
look at what the minerals would cost you
this coffee is a serious bargain because
trace minerals are really expensive as a
supplement so by building them into the
coffee to make sure the coffee's even
cleaner than it already was you're
getting like the most amazing coffee
that tastes good with Crema but you're
getting a huge amount of trace minerals
that would otherwise cost you a lot more
to get in your diet so it's it's meant
to be it's meant to be something that
feels different even if you drink it
black and if you put butter in MCT in it
it's great and you know Bulletproof
Coffee is is good coffee it's you know
it's my baby it's a company I created
and this is something different because
it's danger coffee has minerals in it
and it's it's a different grade than
anything else that's out there and you
know when you drink it like it feels
different right yeah yeah I mean I've
just started today but I haven't ate and
it's 12 30 I haven't ate since like 5 30
yesterday so nice I'd say it's working I
would say and I mean look how look how
you're downloading stuff left and right
I'm just gonna say it gave you psychic
powers right
put that on the bag too
gives you psychic powers I love that I
love it okay look we've gone on and on
I've got to let you go but I love
talking to you I I'm super excited about
this coffee but more than anything
excited about what you're doing in the
world truly uh thanks Danica I am hoping
to see you at the biohacking conference
and biohackingconference.com for people
listening hopefully you'll be there
September 15th to 17th in Beverly Hills
and if not I'll swing by Scottsdale one
of these days and we'll hang out I love
that I love that thank you we'll we'll
get some downloads we'll spiral our
energy there you go
awesome thanks Dave
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today I hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the Subscribe button